match des grands jours ce dimanche le 18
février à plaisir le club local affronte
maul pour une place en demi-finale de la
coupe des yvelines équilibrée sur les 45
premières minutes le match se débloque
juste avant la mi-temps après ce but
inscrit par l'attaquant kevin leur folle
ans c'était dur on l'appelle beaucoup
d'occasions on appelle de beaucoup
d'occasions mais le plus important de
façon c'est d'avoir mis le but 1-0 pour
être obligé de se découvrir et je pense
que c'est là qu'on est les meilleurs
une fin de première période idéale sur
laquelle l'entraîneur plaisir oie s'est
appuyé pour qu'on soit son discours à la
mi-temps ne pas s'énerver poser le
ballon et jouer surtout voilà c'est
vraiment notre qualité sur laquelle on
s'appuie sur de plus les milanais donc
et puis je pense qu'ils sont un peu
stressés donc vraiment détendre tout ça
message reçu par les joueurs les
plaisirs one nerveux ne parviennent pas
à ressortir le ballon et commet de
nombreuses fautes
sanction immédiate moule revient à
égalité après dix minutes de jeu en
seconde période
un avantage de courte durée plaisir
reprend la main sur penalty après ce but
la tension change de camp les joueurs de
maule durcissent le jeu plaisir à
l'occasion de tuer le match à plusieurs
reprises la libération viendra
finalement dans les arrêts de jeu le
héros du jour mamadou syma qu'on s'offre
un doublé sur penalty de penalty
c'est la chance on va dire ça c'est
rentré c'est rentré et voilà tout c'est
un joueur que qui revenu au club il ya
trois ans et qui cette année
marche très très bien après on peut pas
retenir une prestation que d'un joueur
je pense que c'est l'ensemble de
l'équipe qui a été très bonne on fait le
boulot c'était difficile mathieu match
assez compliqué on ne savait pas c'est
une belle équipe de maule très très beau
match plaisant et on a réussi à gagner
donc c'est important d'aller l'aller en
demi-finale en demi-finale plaisir
affrontera mort pas une équipe qui
évolue en d1 de district une division au
dessus des plaisirs oit la rencontre se
disputera le dimanche 1er avril de la
foudre ou au stade bernard giraud